Cris Collinsworth the great analyst for
NBC Sunday Night Football joins us Chris
good morning I feel like I played you
know where you get so tired but you're
just so jacked up and I was I was that
way where at the end of that game you
know it's like 10:30 11 o'clock I'm like
I'm ready to go ready to play I was on
my exercise bike at midnight because I
couldn't sleep I was just because I
never do that right I never sit and
watch seven hours of football
back-to-back I just don't have time
during the day we're getting ready for
Sunday you know all that kind of stuff
and I forgot how much fun it was I mean
I I just it was just tremendous
obviously the games were unbelievable
but it was just so much fun to sit
around and watch those games it was it
was tremendous all right is there a way
if you if the NFL said Chris what would
you do how would you prevent something
that happened like that we saw in the
Saints game in the Rams going forward
because it always takes a big play
controversial play and then we have
changed is there enough controversy that
the NFL is going to change how they
would react to a call like you had in
the Saints game or the non call you know
what do I know I mean the only thing
that I'll tell you is for 25 years there
whatever however long I've been on
television I've been begging people to
allow the past interference to be
reviewable I go there's only one call
there's only one call in the National
Football League
that changes games that literally
changes who wins and loses football
games and it's pass interference or non
pass interference that's it
that's the only one and and when you're
talking about those kinds of potential
50-yard penalties and you can't review
that and the very essence of replay is
supposed to to take care of the call
where everybody in the stadium and all
50 or 60 million people watching at home
know that
the call is wrong they know the call is
wrong the poor official is sitting there
on the field watching instant replay on
the big board probably for the four
thousandth time I'm sure they ran it and
replayed it and replayed it on that big
screen up there and even he knows it's
wrong and they can't fix it well that's
that's a poor use of replay and I think
that as you're talking about ways to fix
it it's let them have two challenges no
matter what it is and you know the
danger in that Dan is that every big
play right so we're going to get a 60
yard run and so once Bill Belichick
going to do he's going to challenge the
play because surely there's holding on
there somewhere right but my opinion is
who cares you know you get to use them
where you where you want to use them
take a chance if you want to on a big
play but it's really hard when the poor
official sitting in the stadium knows
he's wrong and can't fix it can you help
another official that we see this in
baseball sometimes and I don't know in
the moment could you have had an
official come over and say hey you know
what we missed one here my son Jack
turned to me immediately and he goes
watch this dad they're gonna huddle up
and or in change this at all and and I
and I was like you know I you're smarter
than I and that's exactly what they're
going to do let me give you a little bit
of the mechanics of what happens on
those plays just so people understand
that though so there are five officials
assigned to the five eligible receivers
okay so they're going to follow that
receiver no matter where he goes and I'm
sure they have a way of switching off on
crossing routes I don't know all the
mechanics of it but but essentially
there is one official whose only job is
to watch that receiver and so is it
possible that nobody else saw it maybe
but you would think once the ball is in
the air your eyes are going to naturally
go and remember the to the umpire and
the referee in the backfield
they're sort of looking diagonally
across at the far tackle that that's
sort of angle but you would think and so
in the
three who has to get in front of America
and make the call he's going to stay
with the quarterback so he's going to
stay focused even after the ball is
thrown so he's not going to be able to
see this so it's really going to be up
to one of those other officials who had
a responsibility to watch their receiver
who then is going to have to swing over
and look at that play and and come in
and have the guts to change it down what
I've always if you're a conspiracy
theorist my theory was always that al
river on really you wouldn't tell you
this but he really has access to that
referee on the field and he can click in
and go hey why don't you guys huddle up
on that one and see if anybody had a
different opinion which would be sort of
code for we screwed that up can we fix
it before this thing gets out of control
but apparently they don't do that either
so it's a tough moment you know the city
of New Orleans I'm sure is heartbroken
over it made a little bit easier by the
fact that they did get the ball back at
the end of the game and couldn't take
advantage of it but it's one that's
going to live throughout the offseason
yeah and that and that no call may cause
some people their jobs
it cost a team and a city a chance to go
to the Super Bowl again I mean it I
don't know if it brings about change and
I don't know if I have just like you I
don't know if I have you know an option
here that makes this worthwhile but
maybe it is you get two of those wild
card you know challenges and if the
Saints had already used them then they
they wouldn't have been able to go back
I just thought the officials would have
if you ask them now should you guys have
huddled up and actually made that
decision to overturn that and every one
of those guys would probably go yeah you
have the technology or you least had the
people there and they saw it and they
knew it and I agree I think the head of
officials has some kind of communication
with the head official to say take a
look at it again or huddle up guys
because you know that was an egregious
agreed just non call there so what made
it really interesting was that the
receiver didn't pop up and immediately
start screaming
you know and
we all get tired of crybaby receivers
and all that kind of stuff but there
comes at that instantaneous moment where
that official has to make a split-second
decision that's going to decide who's
going to go to the Super Bowl or not you
think about the pressure of that moment
and if the if the receiver isn't even
arguing it I think it tends to swing
your thought process and then maybe he
really didn't do it in some way if you
were leaning that way anyway that's
interesting talking to Chris
Collinsworth from NBC Sports joining us
Dan Patrick show was there a coaching
decision that you questioned
interestingly the only one that I would
have done differently and you know it
PFF we do all the math I've got more
mathematicians that I didn't they have
in colleges I think was the the fourth
and one field goal for Sean and I think
the math would have said to go for it
there because it's a very worst you know
you got whatever it would be 65% chance
of scoring from the the one-yard line
there if you miss it you're gonna leave
them backed up on the one-yard line
which gives you a great chance of
getting the ball back at midfield and
you still have a chance for another
touchdown or a field goal that it's all
about possession right that that was the
one that in a pure mathematical
situation you probably go for that
fourth and one but it also is that's a
tough call too you've been battling back
all day and did not tie that game up at
that point and change the momentum I
think that's where the human element of
the math sometimes kicks in yeah I'm
right there with you because I thought
you know this is the guy who uses
analytics more than anybody else he's
the young bright offensive minded head
coach and of course you're gonna go for
it on the road because I don't want to
get Brees any any chance here coming
back to haunt me and if you score the
touchdown then you know I put even more
pressure on them I think I think Sean
McVeigh in retrospect did the right
thing in the moment of understanding my
defense is pretty good and I'm not too
worried about Brees because this offense
has not been explosive the last six
seven weeks of the season I like my
chances here and maybe that's what Sean
McVeigh
that's how he reasoned that call well
you can't argue with anything that young
coach has done I mean he is he really
has his finger on the pulse of bad
football team I thought their ability to
overcome that crowd noise because so
much of the magic of what they do and it
was explained pretty well in the
broadcast is their ability to use all
the way down to 15 seconds on the on the
shot clock if you will and there is a
lot of communication that goes on
between McVeigh and golf
until that 15-second shutoff come so
they snap to the line of scrimmage the
defense if they don't get in what
they're going to play they snap the ball
quickly and burn you or if you do get in
what they're going to play then McVeigh
has a chance to look at it and then call
the right play the interesting thing
about it is watching the second game the
Patriots have the same thing only they
don't need the coordinators to say if
they've got top rating you know I mean
that it is amazing to watch because
you'd as a defense this is the
interesting part as a defense you
playing the Patriots you decide what Tom
Brady's gonna call you decide so
whatever you do he's going to get to the
weakness of that defense and every
defense has a weakness but it is amazing
to watch him process what's going on and
it's it's one thing to do it pre snap
it's another thing to do it post now I
mean it is really hard that second third
down and ten or whatever it was they hit
to Gronkowski on the slant there I mean
Eric Barry jumped outside clearly jumped
outside expecting Sorenson to make a
play on that slam I mean so they set it
up exactly for what they wanted exactly
what they wanted Tom Brady to do with
that ball and he's still completed it on
third down in ten
I mean it's sick to watch them that the
patients they showed running the
football when that when the defense
dictated that this is a hey if we're
gonna force you to run the football and
Brady time after time said okay we'll
run the football and they kept picking
up first downs doing it that way most
teams in that kind of pressure situation
don't
the guts on second intend to turn around
and hand that thing off they did it all
day when you're watching a game do you
watch a game the way Romo broadcast a
game like do you give the this is what I
think is going to happen you can't
because you can't see the whole field
okay you know that's that's the it's I
love it and you know we all love having
a week off this is the first week off
we've had and whatever six months and so
I love having a week off it was great
but I also miss all the tools that I
have in my disposal to watch the game
including seeing - all 22 you know and
seeing that the end zone and seeing all
the different ways that I can watch it
so I'm anxious to go back and watch
those games again so I can understand
kind of what the game plan was but isn't
it amazing that the Patriots can come
out and do the same thing all the time
on defense they you knew they're gonna
take away he'll the only Pasi caught was
on double coverage and they were going
to take away Kelsey probably by jamming
him at the line of scrimmage although
you know I probably wasn't that focused
to see exactly what was going on down
the field but they take away their two
biggest threats and the the the Chiefs
adjusted you know in the second half
they came back and had a really nice
game plan but the first half performance
of the offense cost them a trip to the
Super Bowl if they just had a moderate
performance in the first half you know
trying to adjust to whatever was
Belichick was doing over there if they
just had you know ten points they
probably went again and I know that
Brady and the Patriots are polarizing
for a variety of reasons but as I said
about 25 minutes ago that appreciate
this because this it you know it's rare
when this happens that you have two
teams two players one player a head
coach that you know we're in this moment
it's like Jordan I savored every moment
of that Borg Macra no bird magic this is
Brady playing at an unbelievable level
that we may never see anything close to
this whether you like him or not whether
you appreciate him now or in 10 years
this is a real special
for a quarterback in the history of the
game and I think maybe Brady eases into
the conversation of is he Michael Jordan
like I know Jordan never lost but is
Brady I mean is he is he in there with
Michael Jordan I would say yes and
here's the reason why
because in basketball a great player or
two and you know way more about
basketball than I do but in basketball
it feels like a great player or two can
swing the lead right you can really
swing the league and say all right
LeBron go to LA and that's going to make
a big difference or goes to Cleveland
and you know whatever those kinds of
players can do that Jordan certainly
could do that in football it's much
harder to do that because the component
parts being put together every year and
being broken down and put back together
every year is such an important piece of
the National Football League I mean the
league was built so that nobody can do
this nobody should be able to do this
and yet here after year after year
you're just stupid and preseason if you
don't pencil the Patriots at least in
the championship game and I watched we
called the the Detroit Lions game where
Patricia beat up on Belichick and the
Patriots and they look terrible and
their offense was terrible and you know
and it was September but here's what the
Patriots do in September I always tell
everybody don't pay any attention to
them because they're experimenting
they're taking all these new guys and
they're trying them in ten different
roles and they're they're teaching them
ten different defenses so that when we
get to playoff time whatever defense
they want to dial up they have two or
three or four games of experience of
having done that so that the rolodex is
so thick for the Patriots and for
Belichick come playoff time
whatever your weakness is they're going
to know it and they're going to attack
it with something they've played at
least three or four games doing so while
you're doing one defense the teams do
just the Seattle cover three or whatever
and they're really good at it by week
five of this
right because they that's all they do
whereas the Patriots are the complete
opposite of that the Patriots are our
we're going to do this this week and
this this week and this this week I'm
going to play him it did linebacker then
I'm gonna play him a rush in then I'm
gonna put them inside a defensive tackle
then I'm gonna drop him to safety and
and by the time Kyle van Noy gets to a
playoff day he can do everything right
Patrick Chung can do everything and and
that kind of patience not many teams can
do it and I'm not sure you could do it
unless you had a superstar quarterback
that could win some of those games you
know and keep you in the hunt but that
is unbelievable how much it shows up
come playoff time
great stuff Chris as always thanks for
another great season and we appreciate
you joining us my pleasure Dan guitar
Chris Collinsworth football night in
America for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]